[Music]
you were good friends with president
carter you were friends with president
carter when he was a governor and he was
one he told you i'm going to be
president someday and you didn't believe
it i laughed so hard about it
you laughed at governor carter when he
said i will be president
well yeah
yeah we're laughing about it now when
was the last when was the last southern
president president before him right
before carter yeah it's after uh
ever after abraham lincoln no no andrew
johnson yeah well wouldn't lbj doesn't
the texas countless itself
all right
sorry all right no no i'm sorry yeah
you
the night of uh carter's inaugural
you were you were invited to the white
house that day one of the first things
that president carter does when two
hours into his presidency is invite you
to the white house is that right right
for dinner
his first dinner
that's pretty amazing when a president
says i'm going to mark my first dinner
i'm going to have greg almond come over
i don't think it was him i think well i
was in
the
i was in the
president lincoln suite
you're in the lincoln bedroom the
bedroom the bed i swear
the bed is about this high yeah and it's
not quite
it's not quite a twin bed
so i mean you're you're like sleeping on
a rail
you know
lincoln wanted his bed fit exactly to
his body remember that
it's six four and a half and very lean
with that on right yeah exactly and
there's a little part of his head
so you slept in the lincoln bedroom when
you first no no no no no no what were
you doing up there i was up there
talking to his
mother
ladies and gentlemen
that's disgusting
[Music]
what's wrong with you people
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
this is your chance to deny some of this
stuff
this is where you jump in greg and you
clear things up
um at the time
at the time yes
so anyway
so anyway
you can't get out of this with snow
anyway no you've probably said enough
anyway the little girl guy's been i've
been but so far in movies amy oh amy amy
comes in his daughter yeah amy comes in
the room and says mama says y'all going
to stay for dinner
and i said no no
she sounds like a hillbilly i mean
that's pretty
mama going to have you over dinner
they are from georgia i know but they
don't
we're going to have some puzzle pie
so she so amy came in and said you're
going to you're going to have dinner
with me tell me a better president we've
had since
i agree never fired a shot jimmy carter
and somehow he got to be the poster boy
for being a [ __ ] that's actually
strength
when you don't have to fire
amen amen
amen he's religious now
[Applause]
it um be done